ÇAm 12. Januar 2012 ...
... kam ich aus der Schweiz zurŸck.
UrsprŸnglich war ich ein ganzes Jahr in Korea.
Also ging ich mit Kollegen an eine Party.
Dort begegnete ich Nina.
FŸr mich war es Liebe auf den ersten Blick.
Ich konnte an nichts anderes mehr denken.È
ÇEin GlŸck, dass sie schnell auch
von mir angetan war.
Nach drei, vier Wochen
kamen wir dann zusammen.
Seither sind wir zusammen.
Wir wohnten dann bald auch zusammen,
was in Korea ein Tabu ist.
Aber wir taten es einfach.È
ÇAnschliessend bat mich ihr Vater
um ein GesprŠch.È
ÇSie hatten so etwas wie ein
offizielles Treffen.
Er fragte ihn aus und ŸberprŸfte
seinen Studentenausweis ...
...und die IdentitŠtskarte.È
ÇDieses GesprŠch verlief recht gut.
Ich glaube, er merkte, ...
...dass mir Nina ebenso
am Herzen liegt.È
ÇEs ging gut, weil er ein netter
und offener Typ ist.
Und anschliessend lief alles
erstaunlich rund. È
ÇMein erster Eindruck war so,
wie ich es erwartet hatte.
Sehr friedlich und ruhig,
wunderbare Natur Ÿberall.
Es liefen sogar kleine Schafe
durchs Dorf,...
...das fand ich sehr lustig.
Es war extrem anders als Seoul,
wo ich herkomme.È
ÇDas klingt jetzt vielleicht komisch, ...
... aber ich wusste bereits am ersten Tag,
dass ich sie heiraten will.
Aber in einer idealen Welt,
ich bin ja nicht religišs, ...
... hŠtte ich gewartet mit der Heirat,
bis wir Kinder haben.È
ÇIch fŸhle mich zuhause, wenn ich
mit Menschen bin, die ich liebe.
Bei Raphael fŸhle ich mich zuhause.
Es hat nicht soviel
mit dem Land zu tun.È
ÇMan spŸrt eine Verantwortung, ...
... weil man eine Person, die man liebt ...
... aus ihrem Umfeld reisst ...
...und sie an einen Ort bringt, ...
... an welchem zu Beginn
eine totale AbhŠngigkeit besteht.
Man mšchte, dass es gut kommt,
weiss aber auch, ...
... dass es fŸr die Beziehung
eine Belastung sein kann.È
ÇIch wŸrde sagen, denkt nicht zuviel
und seid nicht kompliziert.
Es funktioniert, wenn
man sich wirklich liebt ...
... und zusammen sein will.
Das habe ich nun auch gelernt
in diesem Prozess.
Es ist eine spannende Reise!
Denkt nicht zuviel und wagt es!È